it is time for drew's news your daily
bleep
from the good news robot
i can't do the robot
you know who does the robot the best
leonardo dicaprio really
the words of paris hilton so
hot well with me at the desk is the
hottest man in town also my co-pilot
ross matthews
hi everybody
first up in the news we're starting with
the latest fashion trend this is so fun
the new york post says that people are
showing off their bagel pride with deli
core
god it never stops you guys local bagel
shops are pumping out custom merch so
you can rep your favorite local deli in
style here's some examples pete davidson
is on trend here with uncle paulie's
the hat he is wearing that's a deli in
la and then fellow hottie jake
gyllenhaal teamed up with russ and
daughters for a limited locks a
sweatshirt and then coach and zaybars
got together
and they had a bagel bag baby retailing
at 550 which sounds like a lot of money
but it sold out yeah you know it's not a
lot of money for a bagel bag but it is a
lot of dough
thank you so stupid
but i love that this wearing your bagel
pride is now a trend do you know how
long i've been doing it like this is a
bagel this is a bagel this is a bagel
i've been wearing it for years that's
where i was going with it too next up
everyone loves to get a taste of texas
including wonderful prince harry people
reports that he was recently spotted in
fort worth wow that's right we love fort
worth attending his very first rodeo he
went to the stockyard championship and
one coach said it was the first prince
he'd ever seen at the rodeo
now chip and joe your texas royalty have
you ever been told that you kind of sort
of have some
similarities with a harry and a meghan
is there some symmetry i love this
comparison for sure i like picturing him
at a you know he went from buckingham
palace to bucking bronco can you imagine
well like him in a really like giddy up
horse
i can see them anywhere now because
they're going everywhere and they're
living their dream and they broke out
and i'm just like they're the living
example of don't stay stuck
well we've got to take a moment to
celebrate uh the life and work of an
incredible woman cnn reports betty reed
sawskin the oldest ranger in the
national park service well she just
retired rossi at the age of
100. wow
betty worked at a park in richmond
california that is dedicated to
highlighting the works of americans on
the home front during world war ii and
betty was one of those women after
facing discrimination in the air force
she went on to work for the boilermakers
auxiliary union yeah and betty's work
shed light on the diverse group of
americans who supported the war but
often went unnoticed in the history
books and you can hear betty's entire
story in her own words online and the
infos on our website congratulations
betty thank you for your incredible
service 100 years like that is an
extraordinary life
we've got a beautiful moment from oak
hill elementary school in georgia the
head custodian there lana gashenko is a
ukrainian with a family living back home
in ukraine and usa today reports that
the students at the school wanted to
show her that they were thinking about
miss lana so they put up this surprise
art project and it's dozens of
hand-drawn sunflowers the national
flower of ukraine and messages hoping
for peace and safety from miss lana's
family and all of ukraine
i know
[Applause]
i don't think that needs any words
[Music]